and uh and chappelle's roommate which is
the most important thing yeah yeah we're
trying to just hold on to him and get
his numbies
i've got a lot i've had some nice uh
roommates if you guys want to pop in the
city be my roommate my roommate before
was trevor wallace oh damn fight company
he had uh
what did he have right
[Music]
how's chappelle doing
well that's good yeah no i don't know
what he's doing today but he was they
had a
another show last night the band
he's leaned into that he's like band
practice a lot and [ __ ] like that yeah
they had a show last night somewhere on
fairfax and i guess it went pretty well
yeah it's crazy did you even post about
it no he didn't uh he he might have
posted like
videos from the thing but i didn't know
about until yesterday welcome welcome to
cats after dark the uh thick boy king of
the sting after show i want to see these
videos because it's mad peaceful looks
like this show the show's an experience
yeah matt being uh chappelle's band yes
um
but yeah he performed last night do you
know where it was somewhere on fairfax i
don't know it looked like a little
outdoor thing but he uh i think it was
in his story there
and our fans may recognize our guests
it's white mike turner the blanquito
miguelito uh stand-up comedian
uh seventh to fifteenth biggest
celebrity out of cleveland right now in
the power rankings so cincinnati
jacket green jacket
and uh and chappelle's roommate which is
the most important thing yeah yeah yeah
we're trying to just hold on to him and
get his numbies
i've got a lot of i've had some nice uh
roommates if you guys want to pop in the
city be my roommate my roommate before
was trevor wallace oh damn
he had uh
what did he have yeah right i just went
over there not to flex too hard but he
had i think a million instagram
followers when i moved in and he's he he
left with 2.4
and i think it was all to do with me i
shot and edited all his videos no loss
ain't no laws
um yeah that was him that was chappelle
last night rocking
he said [ __ ] podcasting i'm gonna scream
into a mic in a different way it's such
a
perfect name for a punk bad mad peaceful
yeah i agree and and then you got that
one
oh that dude is actually a comic i know
him
he's got a film crew too
okay i was gonna say that so that guy is
doing his impression of someone moshing
yeah yeah and he's not actually doing
what he's supposed to be doing uh yeah i
can't do that [ __ ] anymore once i turned
30 i got out of mosh pits
i went to a run the jewels concert and
threw my back out
ran too hard he ran too hard yeah yeah
chapel took his shirt off
is it is it crazy living with a rock
star
it's different than a comedian it's uh
it's funny because it's like
um
yeah
i don't know you he's just in the shower
and he'll be listening to like gin
blossoms and then he'll be listening to
like slipknot yeah and it's like is
everything all right in there wait so
where was that concert that was
somewhere on fairfax
somewhere on fairfax yeah somewhere in
fairfax it looks like a like a parking
lot or something yeah
um oh that's toby toby's og yeah so they
went to the uh
they they're with the games fourth of
july party yesterday yeah enough about
chapel he left us he quit yeah talk
about white mike turner yeah this is the
yeah i get to just be around
people doing cool [ __ ] i i distracted
myself when i [ __ ] up cincinnati
cleveland did i even list off uh you're
the star of obi wan yeah
um what am i on the call number two on
the call
yeah i was i was in obi-wan
it and when they posted like the week of
uh
the promotion it came out what like a
month or two ago i think i don't know if
you guys watched it i don't watch star
wars stuff so i don't know but i know
it's huge it is huge it's the wrong one
it's huge
and so like one of the promotional
photos was this photo and people started
tagging me on twitter and they're like
dude are you in this [ __ ]
and it looks like from this picture
once my head gets out of the way
because i'm explaining what's going on
it looks like i'm like
he's obi-wan i'm ob2 dude yeah you're
part of it
i'm obi-wan kahoe dude
now did you say those jokes in that tic
tac i said some i said something about
uh
what i said looked like obi-wan knows me
uh
and then i was just saying how it looks
like i'm like the right-hand man like i
was the dude that was the comic relief
for the whole show
uh
little do you know from this picture i
was just an extra and that picture just
look makes it look like i'm like in it
so you're not much of a star wars fan
though or i'm a star trek guy okay i was
raised by you know jean-luc picard
um i had an absent father and uh
picard really showed me what a man could
be in uh intergalactic uh
political systems
i i also had an absent father so i was
like i needed to be like i wanted
anything manly so i was like not going
to get into either that nerdy [ __ ] star
trek or star wars
yeah but now i realize that it's just
really good art and way ahead of its
time
star trek star trek uh next generation
the one with picard is on netflix
and it's very good
still like you'll watch it and you're
like oh this is just good tv i mean you
could
also shout out to my not absent father
he's the only reason i watched star trek
um but you know he was he was here and
there
yeah i could never get into star trek i
tried so many times it's just not my
thing
yeah yeah
i mean
i think you're the key demo for it too
it reminds me of my life yeah yeah
yeah
uh no star trek was cool yeah but so
star wars was cool i was always i don't
know i've watched all the [ __ ] yeah you
watch it yeah i'm yeah pretty big fan i
would say haven't watched all like the
animated stuff but i oh yeah
here and there have there's so many of
those animated um
legos movies with it no i haven't seen i
played the video game lego star wars
video games oh yeah you did
yeah playstation 2. those got insane
ratings and electronic gaming monthly
yeah when i still had it but like how
you didn't watch the cartoons to a point
they're just bastards bastardizing the
ip they're just like oh yeah let's do
[ __ ]
little red riding hood star trek yeah
but the the clone wars animated um show
is like regarded as like one of the best
like shows in the star wars prop like
well [ __ ] content out there i don't
know about the other ones like rebels um
i thought it's like all right and i
think there's another one the bad batch
it's alt-right
all right
yeah
all right
yeah
okay
are you good yeah i'm okay oh yeah i
think i'm gonna make it you mentioned
something embarrassing off air that the
last time you were here i wore this you
wore the same shirt
100
both times it's way off season for nfl
football oh it's deep offseason yeah but
uh it's you know what you guys still got
a quarterback that's good it's a nice
material that kind of hangs and doesn't
really hug as much the yeah the
stomach even though i'm not on the couch
anymore i moved up so i don't have to
worry about that that's big for you yeah
you feeling good about where your team
is at i don't really follow off season
news i'm like uh
i love
sunday football nothing better than the
packer game but like i don't even know
who we drafted i couldn't tell you i
don't know i i i hate i know that you
have zero wide receivers yeah and i
don't think they can firmly say that and
then they were like let's not draft one
yeah that's like the thing for like the
past 12 years like yeah it's great not
helping randall cobb honestly if it was
still 2011 you guys would have a great
roster hell yeah haha clinton dicks
that's how i that's how i end up in
fantasy sports you don't know how hot
clinton dicks
he was he's a packers legend yeah and
dicks
clinton
is she still around uh i think he might
be on the
bears he yeah he was on the bears for a
little bit i don't even know if he
stopped
wait he's his first name is haha and his
last name is clinton dix yeah i mean
that's like a little more reasonable
than your first name being haha no i
mean he was named during the lewinsky
trials
the whole thing is his first yeah
this will probably age well
clinton dixon yeah
yeah it's like someone's haha clinton
dicks
getting sucked off
um shout out to monica he went to
alabama right he's a bama boy he won a
championship he's good
but yeah you guys are you guys are doing
uh okay i guess huh full name hashon
and he was like let's go with haha
it's memorable [ __ ]
um
but yeah then i saw your quarterback i
was i ran into aaron rodgers and uh
yeah i ran into your father yeah he was
in tatooine he's more like oh my gosh
yeah brett's my dad is yeah brett is a
good man i used to call uh
i used to go to denny's and order a
brett favre slam and uh it's just the
all-american
um
they knew it they knew what was going on
they're like excuse me i was like the
all-american thank you where did you run
into uh oh yeah he complimented my
mustache look at on uh instagram i'm
brandon with the waste management open
in uh beautiful scottsdale arizona on
yours uh yeah
no it's on uh chappelle's well i don't
know
i don't know he thought of this guy
he's on aaron rodgers unfortunately what
do you do he's been
so hit that one
you can turn that little volume up if
you need to
volume
so this is me talking to adam thielen
i don't know before rogers announced he
was back on the team
and he just wanted him to leave the
nfc north hey adam can we talk about why
you're really here to convince aaron
rodgers to retire is that fair
i don't know about that i don't i don't
know i just want him to get traded to a
different debate
yeah maybe i don't want to retire yeah
okay aaron i just talked to adam he said
he's here to convince you to leave the
division
yeah that's going to take a lot of
convincing
come on now what you still looking at
property in denver what are you thinking
hey dude it's through the roof you see
property value over there i have not no
capitol hill it's not easy are you a
real estate agent no i know a guy
wow got competition for the best
mustache on the green today my mustache
looks like it's about to get arrested by
his mustache that mustache doesn't have
hands but somehow it's handsy mr phelps
you got does your mustache have any
advice for my mustache
no i think yours looks great yeah you
got i got to let it breathe a little bit
more or anything it's got a lot of go
yeah yeah just let it rip it's a good
stash i i love growing a good stash oh
he's probably good six weeks is that six
weeks that thing looks like it's a
roadie for brooks and dunn
and then i had another one where then
went back to rogers i edited out of that
one that he uh
he he complimented my uh my mustache and
that really honestly
put a lot of faith in me
um i needed somebody to really look me
in the face and say this thing is
working yeah i i love the man and he's
composed he's cool he's funny but i
don't know if he's the guy to take
advice from he's he's
i don't know
he's banged some pretty good looking
broads have you seen the newest broad um
have you do you know her name oh yeah
isn't it uh the chick from shailene
woodley no they are
uh blue of earth he broke up with
shailene woodley well that's not a great
look they might even even is she really
is shayleen woodley really in uh hunger
games no shows divergence i heard the
same movie oh is miles teller in
divergent you know what if you're gonna
i don't know if i saw a divergent i'd be
lying to you yes i did i don't think he
was in it there was another guy who did
kind of look like him in it though okay
because
for some reason shayla when aaron was
with shailene woodley he would like
double date with miles teller and his
girlfriend all the time they're a little
nice oh maybe
but she so i was wondering if maybe
shailene and miles developed their
friendship on the set of diversion
that's where mine was going that would
make sense that connects a lot of the
dots are connecting there but now he
dumped her because he's like you're not
earthy enough for me
yeah you make your own so who is this
charlotte brederton
yeah blue earth uh is it is that a real
name
charlotte
but her real name is
is she a witch yeah
yeah i think it's wiccan so she's from
l.a
but aren't wiccans witches
what does that mean wiccan i don't know
what this is we're about to learn
just take your time googling we would
now want to see the wikipedia on wiccan
or wicca
what hey
so what
yeah
they met in sedona which explains a lot
yeah she definitely could be a witch
um a lot of vortexes over there
i i know someone who is invited to uh go
on a hiawaska trip with uh aaron rodgers
that's cool yeah he's he's he's
he's a joe rogan disciple is basically
uh what you need to know about rogers at
this point
aren't we all we are
great [ __ ] point man what is blue of
earth what is this uh so she says she's
my p.s my name is is blue not blue of
earth she says in a series of instagram
uh stories posted on thursday i do not
identify as a witch and i do not
identify
i do not identify as a witch y'all are
hilarious i'm sure the cause she
identifies as the wicked google wicket
just play football
yeah right just slang it dude so when
she votes he's got a weird taste i don't
know i like rogers
when blue roots for the packers it like
does she go like support the blue cheese
you know
the area i mean
are you a writer
man she has changed him so fast
yeah
he looks not
i don't want that guy under center
yeah that guy owns the chicago bears
upgrade dude yeah
he looks so young too
what are you into witches over here what
do you think i'm not like
like star wars lego movies
uh can't can't do it the witches though
but there was that you guys remember
that scooby-doo movie where they had
like the three witch sisters oh yeah or
whatever
i thought he was talking about hocus
pocus i think he's talking
i'd
about
jump into hocus pocus than where i was
going with the scooby-doo yeah
but now you've got too far and we have
to know
you guys don't want to know about the
scooby-doo thing the three witches and
scooby-doo now it was uh
yeah they're there they had some like
badass like musical numbers with these
chicks i mean that explains delicious
bridges younger it's the younger hoes
yeah
well that's pretty neat so you would a
new hocus pocus uh they did make a new
hookup do you know where it was filming
it's already made you know where it was
filmed salem right at this high school
lasalle football yeah which lasalle oh
and california here no no
they filmed at my house oh damn they
that's really neat to brag that's your
brand
brothers went to my house and you're
like well they filmed hocus pocus too
i'm not in high school i'm a huge
halloween fan and i love hocus pocus so
that's like a big thing really what's
your best halloween costume you've ever
had ghost a ghost it was a ghost but it
looked like something else though he was
in the kkk yeah yeah
yeah
uh who's the most famous person to come
from everybody's high school
from and send that into us cats after
dark send in a video we want to know the
most famous person go to your high
school but
do you have anybody
the uh
benny the jet rodriguez from san jose oh
[ __ ] yeah
yeah that's a great place that is pretty
good where'd you go to high school saint
francis and la canada [ __ ] yeah yeah did
he play baseball um
i don't know he was a fireman after and
he was like there for career day and
then
everyone's like hey we thought you were
on the dodgers like yeah
yeah
you're not a slap hitter with speed on
the bases you didn't steal home yeah i
don't i don't know no i'm sure there's a
heart attack star from my high school
now that we don't know about but um i
had uh yeah the isley brothers went
there but i don't think they went like
four years but they were in cincinnati
back in like the
what would have been the 50s or 60s or
something and then um
but the most popular is probably kevin
euclis the baseball player for the red
sox
he won the world series for the red zot
it was a big deal he's banging tom
brady's sister bat stance right he like
pointed his back like kind of forward
yeah he did some weird [ __ ] did he fight
a lot
uh no
no he just hit for power okay i'm just
mixing him up with kyle barnes he
he's a bit he's definitely a big guy
right eucalyptus is a big marshmallow
yeah
that was but that was back when i still
didn't watch baseball i never really
have maybe one year in high school but i
played a ton of fantasy
baseball tell you fantasy baseball is
the best fantasy
if you have the time yeah yeah yeah i
have ruined people's leagues by being
the taco of the group you're the one who
doesn't check it doesn't do anything
yeah you got to do yeah you got to make
moves every day but yeah baseball's hard
man
uh any fantasy football players with
their we have nothing in common as a
group
it's hard to find wait let's finish off
the the high school yeah yeah high
school oh who is the most famous person
to your high school probably uh
big 12 all-conference honorable mention
scott christopherson my close friend in
confidence
dude is he related to chris
christopherson
chris christopherson's kid uh no no well
that's not really cool yeah it's not
cool at all but he's a nice guy where'd
he play big 12 uh iowa state he
initially went to uh marquette tom crean
only like black guys so then he
transferred to jay crowder and jimmy
butler to his his like the coach his
manifest destiny of the guy was supposed
to be his coach fred hoyber like the
same guy yeah fred hoidberg
um yeah that's pretty i wouldn't uh i
would just say nobody
yeah it might be you at this point we'll
look at you i'm trying to so i don't
know if he actually went to the high
school but he was there for a thing
and i believe he was like an alma mater
so i remember nitro from american
gladiator oh [ __ ] yeah you do yeah yeah
i think he was actually someone that
tended to be [ __ ] cool yeah
you guys wouldn't know
i think i do i'm confused how you think
he might have just possibly been there
because i remember so leo moonfire punky
brewster i don't know if you guys that's
always old school huge tits she has huge
sets she came to school too but i think
it was two different times and i think
he came as one of the people that
actually went to our high school
saddleback high school in santa ana
that's dope yeah yeah he's from san jose
university oh yeah saddlebag heist oh
[ __ ] there you go it says it right there
okay
okay
okay uh i think it's actually he wrote a
book a true story of roid's rage and
redemption
i'd like to hear about his redemption i
don't think he redeemed himself he was
cool because i i mean for us because we
were asian most of my friends
so you've been asian you've been asian
for a long time but i mean i was like
the first sort of asian guy i saw that
was a cool guy on tv you know what i
mean he was like a cool i didn't even
know he's eight yeah
that was enough for me that was the
thing you guys are yeah he looks enough
asian to me i think he's a black man i
know what is he
white
he's definitely white his last name is
clark like he's got a gladiator there he
looks black
clark clark could be a black name
yeah
but
japan japan
oh wow but that's where he was born that
doesn't necessarily mean i mean
to me that's japanese i think he's not
speaking
like like his dad's japanese mom
was he like the american samurai instead
i've been doing a gladiator i've been
doing the hardcore history of uh japan
pre-world war two
they were doing some [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
they [ __ ] destroyed our people oh and
[ __ ] i would love to listen to something
that would make me feel better about
what we did to them
dude
i mean honestly
i don't think anything justify that
is black yeah i'd see what's over i know
so
yeah and he's clearly watched a lot in
japanese bruce lee stuff
what what uh ethnicity and i i'm oh for
the center on this everybody gets it
right what ethnicity is maya rudolph
maya rudolph
i actually think i've isn't she
uh
i mean i don't know black and jewish see
i didn't know she was at all black
everybody knows she's black
that's your problem man yeah how do you
i don't see color yeah that's true
unless it's yellow and green i guess
when you look at her
colors
yeah right
uh yeah and then what she's probably
white too i don't know
i think she's half too she's on snl okay
chin you're winning this game so far
really nacho is the coolest one so far i
i i
i don't know dude kevin eugel has won a
world series yeah very important go to
boston yeah yeah there's a section of
the country where yeah nicholas wins
that game also if
the eisley brothers went to
that but that's way more famous than
anybody yeah you know who the eisley
brothers are you don't see color they're
banned
they're a
a musical group of some sort yeah what
the [ __ ] is going on they're the eyes
they're the most sampled group of all
time in hip-hop music history okay
between the sheets is a song that
matters
yeah they're
this is baby making music oh the love of
you yeah it's just like
some of the movies some wrap socks they
were sampled in yeah so uh between the
sheets between the sheets was sampled on
big east between the sheets is the most
sampled
i don't know if that's actually today
but i know it's one of the most sampled
hip-hop uh samples ever
you want me to go through big lists yeah
look up uh kendrick lamar's eye
biggie big papa okay
lil wayne the receipt or a receipt i
mean uh jay-z ignorant [ __ ]
uh tupac my block
snoop dogg yeah yeah it goes deep thank
you yeah but uh and then yeah the isley
brothers are
uh
were reintroduced to music in the 90s
with you know one of all of our favorite
people r kelly um you're contagious
touch me baby give me all you got
were you having sex in the early 2000s
at all no
i didn't have sex in high school you
didn't have sex in high school mid-2000s
started [ __ ] making up for last time
baby
yeah you should listen to ronald eisley
uh and i i love
i love that era of hip hop and then i
love i found out i love soul music
because of hip hop so the fact that i i
didn't know this is i feel like it's
gone back there somewhere but i'm alone
i might even just cut it all out yeah uh
actually i think a way that might be
able to help your memory flow a little
better
is some
magic mine
nice smooth
transition he's getting the check's
clear
do you want to explain the science
behind this beautiful matcha beverage
absolutely i think the easiest way to
think of it is the anti-procrastination
drink this once daily bottle is made of
12 natural ingredients echinacea
ashwagandha a bunch of other [ __ ] matcha
and it only has 30 milligrams of
caffeine but that that
that alchemy of natural ingredients will
give you a slow zen hum throughout your
day so you're ready and prepared to
attack those tasks that have maybe been
uh an albatross around your neck for for
for hours weeks or days this is what
rogers does he uses his lube for his
witch girlfriend i don't think that
that's not how we're selling magic today
it may or may not be true but mike are
you a man of routine do you do the same
thing every day uh depends sometimes
i'll beat off in the morning sometimes
at night i think it's uh adding
uh huh they just hear that magic mind to
your post nut uh would really kind of
set you off for the day on the right
path yeah kind of replenish all those uh
post-nut clarity with some magic mine
filled in oh oh yeah you feel invincible
you feel a great combination the the
because this is supposed to give you
clarity and so it's post not clarity so
sure it's clarity squared yep uh go to
magicmind.com use promo code dark for 20
off 25 actually i think now and posted
it and if you do order it and use it we
want to zoom in and talk to you and and
hear how magic mind has changed your
life
look at amy j
i think that was my best read ever
cheers to that one cheers cheers
so yeah yeah you have to take that now
the only magic minding it did you get uh
george you got your friend oh yeah oh
yeah
so you did you lefty i am
look at all those benefits on screen
those bannies dude
doggy it's good right it tastes great
it's probably one of the best tastes
it's refreshing i've ever tasted it i
increasingly and we say this every time
we take it but i do like like there's
like this
like i like it i like it no it's not
it's
i think when you're chugging you're like
is this going to taste good it actually
doesn't taste that bad
and the post i like i think what you
think more than that the post
it's like pineapple come the post the
post not clarity on the back no but like
the aftertaste is not bad i think that's
the thing i was worried about i was like
ooh is this going to be no i like to
pre-taste after i like it all yeah you
like it all right magicmind.com
promo code dark for 20 off
what else is going on july did you guys
do anything for july 4th uh no i worked
yeah i watched a little of the hot dog
eating contest which like i'm intrigued
by every year but then i miss it every
year
and are you intrigued to see how much he
wins by
yeah and like
i don't know it's 63 glizzies dude
he needs to rename himself joey hot dogs
really yeah
what does that mean a glizzy at the
turret it's just a hot dog oh really it
happened over the last like year or two
i don't know yeah you don't like
lizzie's
i never heard that lizzy gobblers glizzy
i heard he's like a word for a bunch of
things because i heard someone call a
gun at glizzy before
uh
i'm just a regular gun just as izzy to
anything yeah a glock would be a glizzy
that's why i was like
i i was just it just confused me because
i heard glizzy for dick hot dog guns it
was just weird yeah and you can catch
them all yeah yeah well my buddy dylan
who he also typed he said there's
nothing better than a glizzy at the turn
really this is going to make i'm a big
hot dog guy just in all fast fashions uh
really and so midway through i don't
play golf but i might start now just to
eat a hot dog
half time do you have a preference
you're not a paul b frank guy
uh i'll dude i'll do the shittiest
cheapest chicken and pork really amazing
thing do you like brats yeah big
broccoli matt you a met guy uh uh
like the new york mats do you know what
a met is mm-hmm i don't know if that was
a cincinnati thing or not you guys know
it fill us in
it's just a spicy hot dog really it's
like uh something different
yeah but it's like uh it's got a little
heat to it it's kind of nice
um they sell them at uh reds games in
cincinnati that's for sure
uh call them big red smokies if i recall
we'll have to ask kyle too kyle's from
cincinnati i'm i'm
intrigued yeah mets are good but it's
like yeah it's uh same [ __ ] nick have
you ever have you never been in vicious
dogs in north hollywood uh i haven't if
you're a big hot dog guy you would like
that place i feel like i think you've
done pinks have you done pinks yeah yeah
i've done pink stuff it's pretty solid
yeah i agree the line is never worth it
uh i know that i've lived close by so i
know when to hit it oh i think there's a
nice like three to five i know a guy
yeah
pinky his name's brain
i use i used to work at uh funny or die
okay and that's like just down oh yeah
that's yeah destroyed they're still
there aren't they yeah yeah um i don't
know if they have any employees yet they
keep laying them off in droves really
that was casualty shout out to joey
i'll say that i don't give a [ __ ] uh
clip it send it to him yeah pink's is
good
uh but i always used to go there for
lunch and the line was too long to be
able to get it yeah yeah but like 11 30
to one is like stupid over there yeah
yeah
the hot dog for lunch i feel that like
that really slows you down after yeah
productivity in the afternoon is gonna
just shut down not after a lifetime of
dogs at lunch yeah your body's
conditioned to it if you don't have the
hot dog for lunch so we throw it with
nick this afternoon he didn't have
much
he's actually reeling over there
he just drank
magic mine with no dog come on no glizzy
with his magic yeah i'm like you need
both and he's drunk on whiteclaw we need
to get rid of this guy and i'm here
holding her eyes too much so you guys
did it so july 4th anybody do like
fireworks i was driving around looking
at fireworks last night and
uh they were everywhere right they were
everywhere la is cool to just drive
around
it's not with these guests these cool
ones in beverly hills but nothing
nothing really nice flex dude what are
you doing up in beverly hills i was just
uh i was at my friend's house oh who's
your friend i know um my brother's
manager oh nice yeah you met him haven't
you colin said mark pretty liquid mark
managing market yeah he actually
you already know i mean not you already
know um let's laugh when we did that
show oh yeah it came a couple times
remember me in there it's like morocco
oh he's from japan i redeemed myself
because i was like yeah colin you're
like mark he's a black man from japan
his name is nitro
he was on some show i don't know
oh this guy's this guy's real what are
his cross streets then and then if i'm
living looking at the house what what
it's honestly it's honestly not uh not
like that it's a it's an apartment i got
a question for everyone well you guys
been paying attention to like the nba
this off season i mean i always do yeah
a little bit too much i want to know
how come zion williamson
it got a super max contract and he's
played like 12 games because he
because his potential played like 30
games okay give me credit and he looks
skinny 30 more than me yeah
i didn't know he was up for a contract
so that makes sense because i saw a
picture of him i'm like finally he's
like jacked again
for about six months until you can't you
just can't bail on the asset at this
point is the boring reason yeah but
you're just like you can't you took him
number one overall
he clearly has injuries [ __ ] but
he also just every three months post a
video of him dunking five years he looks
40 five years 46 million a year that's
the cost of uh doing business though but
he's played 30 games so what would you
do would you just cut him he still has
one piece of one more season of
rookie contract right so please but if
you don't do that then you're in a
deandre ayton situation where the sons
and now he's mad
the sons are saying they don't want him
unless they are just being picky you
know
i don't know
i'm sure new york will finally realize
that they want zion williamson and then
he'll get there and he'll have a broken
back and he'll never fight for them i
mean if new york's willing to pay 27
million for jalen brunson who's your
team
i'm from chicago so i'm bulls mostly but
i like most of the nba you know it's
like once you start liking the sport you
kind of like all around that's true
that's that's how i was for the nba for
the longest time i didn't have a team
mm-hmm wisconsin so i mean
bucks were dope and nineteen like
wisconsin who has a team from wisconsin
i mean i mean oh you mean a place that
has when i was young
i was on the the western side of the
state so we didn't get like all the
local games so i barely got to watch
them until they me the playoffs 98 was
dope
uh but
i just fell in love with the nba like i
would watch every single game but now
it's all fights oh yeah you still gotta
come watch fights mike oh
yeah
[Laughter]
again i just like drinking yeah so it
sounds fun do you get fights there's big
fights this weekend there were people
got knocked out
strickland mike here's what uh i don't
know anything about it uh there are a
couple knockouts or not strictly
uh the guy sean strickland he's a
character to look into maybe oh yeah
maybe if you can find a compilation
he's like a
here's an example of this guy he won a
fight and they were interviewing in the
octagon and he was like
i'm just so thankful for fighting if it
wasn't for this sport i'd probably be in
a trailer cooking meth somewhere oh hell
yeah yeah so like that's the kind of guy
that has that self-awareness yeah and
he is not joking like he just talks
about like all the rage he has and this
is the only place he gets out or else he
probably really really hurt somebody um
big big bag there's a lot of videos of
him like pulling up next to people with
his camera he's like pull over and i
will fight you right now
and he's like if you don't have a gun
i'll pull over
for a while he was winning and he was
going crazy on twitter and like the
biggest news but then he got banned from
twitter so
stopped and yeah stopped making waves
for a while banned from twitter what did
he do knock out uh christy mack
the guy doesn't doesn't have limits
we gotta stop this war machine i get it
yeah i don't know
i don't think i like uh
him but he definitely won like the press
conferences like he was there's a wild
boy hype around and then he apparently
he's like x skin head too like that does
not surprise me in the least bit how do
you be an ex skinhead when your hair is
like that it's current
yeah it seems like a current skin or
don't you have like a whole revelation
like uh
eddie norton yeah that's a brother got
killed in the background i just saw that
movie for the first time recently my
favorite romantic guy
it's a great movie
i haven't seen it either we're talking
you've never seen it american history x
where you curb stops yeah yeah are you
not
sure
yeah but you like more of the love story
and the lighthearted that's how they
appreciate the love story between him
and the black man in the laundry room
i see the comedy in it
do you have not seen that film no what i
know do you like movies yeah but i i got
weird blind spots just like things that
have have just always been on the docket
but you just never get to it's a very
good movie and it's a fun uh like behind
the scenes stuff with uh ed norton
wanted that movie to be completely
different he like him and the director
have like classic
hollywood beef
and uh
it made it interesting but movie turned
out good
you know the the black dude that his
romantic partner in the movie sure
he was supposed to yeah he's a comic and
he was supposed to be part of king uh
what do you call that oh the king's
coming oh really yeah but he bailed
because he didn't like something that
was going i don't know this exact story
but he could have been huge
then he opted out he's still a very
well-known
stand-up uh specifically within the
movie sure but he was yeah
yeah he him and his brother both stan
i'm blanking on his name right now me
too would you rather be a king of comedy
or like end racism
okay i feel like the kings of comedy did
more to end racism than that's very than
anybody ever who's do you have a
favorite king of comedy
i mean
bernie mac's guy yeah and his brother's
very funny too birdie mac is probably
the funniest but steve harvey is the
king of the kings of comedy yeah
runs hollywood i'm always a cedric guy
but bernie had the best set on that
night but i just think cedric the
entertainer is always my favorite i
guess i could i i don't know his stand
up i don't think i've seen the
commercial i've seen did you see the
movie no
oh my god what the hell is going on here
is it a movie yeah yeah it's a spikely
directed i mean it's a comedy special
but it's like
yeah yeah they do a little behind the
scenes stuff okay his cedric the
entertainer said is so i mean but
they're all they all do great and steve
harvey
is the host and crushes the whole time
it's funny that d.o hugley didn't it had
the worst set and he still crashed does
said the entertainer have a towel with
him is he wiping his forehead no no he
doesn't do that he wears a suit full
suit yeah and the hat but i feel like
i don't know i mean he's sweating it's
really interesting he's just my favorite
interludes in all of hip-hop history
sure
he's great steve i love the album
both of them bellyville too because i
remember that one it was actually
funnier they're all great bernie and
then bernie was the one that everybody
obviously heightens from this because
then the set that he had turned into the
show and yeah the set that he did
explained
his his
sister that he took his kids
and he had that whole thing and then
they turned it into a tv show which is
one of the best sitcoms oh yeah really
grew up on the bernie mac show
i love sitcoms never see them
yeah i mean my mom used to watch it all
the time oh he used to do he used to
break fourth wall and just go into the
therapy room and just talk to america he
did the smartest career move out of all
of them
uh dying you died
people revere that [ __ ] and not
that they wouldn't of anyways but
i mean steve harvey's not getting his
flowers he's he's polarizing steve steve
steve's sneaking up on dl hugley's not
getting his flowers he gets hated on a
lot you know my favorite thing about
steve harvey is uh the mustache uh
that's up there top five
thing yeah but no in family feud when he
he asks like a really leading question
and then someone gives the most obvious
answer yeah and he acts shocked oh yeah
he liked america
jesus christ
yeah steve is great on that show
i saw yeah said to the entertainer was
shown at the comedy store like two weeks
ago there's there's not a lot of people
i get like geeked up about seeing
but i was like damn that's cedric the
entertainer excuse me mr entertainer
are you a comedy store regular
no oh no like on the wall or anything
yeah no no no i go chill i just kick it
over there because
it's a nice hang for a lot of stand-ups
in la
people that are kind of my peer group in
the scene we can chill over there
sometimes doing spots in the belly room
some of my friends are
regulars there but then also
just doing spots so it's a good good
place to hang it's one of the better
clubs to
chill link up with some people show face
uh they're in the improv are really good
too is comedy 100 of your income yeah
nice nice i haven't had a day job since
2019. [ __ ] yeah yeah he's a he's a young
aspiring comment yeah oh really been
doing it for a couple years now that's
what's up yeah are you funny
i think so yeah george george has seen
me you have electrified people so far on
this show probably not
emerge can vouch for me we already told
the story so like he he invited us to a
comedy show and they messed up the time
and they put him on a sorority woke
liberal gay show baby still the best and
it was very awkward but he did crush her
like he went into a weird environment
and did him and he did it he held his
own a sorority liberal gay show
basically something like that
because i mean if it was a fraternity
show it'd also be gay
but um
that's interesting i'm proud of you yeah
it was good
had the one on friday so you're a comedy
store regularly yeah yeah yeah yeah name
on the wall
that show is in the belly room actually
yeah
uh that's cool how long you two years
yeah but like on and off has coveted and
stuff made it hard yeah it's a tough
time to start yeah but i started i was
living in new york city at the time of
it 2019 and yeah that's where i took
like a class at the seller and that's oh
really how like i was nervous to do it i
was like if i just take this and then
you have to go on and do like that
showcase
it'll help me
like
force myself to do it yeah it's a tough
game yeah and these are tough cities to
start in new york and l.a are the worst
cities to start in but you got to just
keep keep pushing i think i had an
advantage of being in phoenix
because you can just
do so much time and
you're bad but
how good is good in that city
um i think that is not the prevailing
sentiment uh
that
it's bad to start in new york or l.a
like people i think get up they'll
i don't know quit their job live in
their car
uh i think if you talk to stand-ups i
think that that i i know that i mean
amongst yeah so like maybe outside
looking in wouldn't think that i know
that i was able to move in a way in
phoenix to just get your chops up and
like
um
when you get to la and new york then
everything is about your first
impression of people
so when you come to new york and you're
starting out if i'm a big dog in new
york or l.a and i see you when you're
starting out first couple years not that
this is going to happen you shouldn't
overthink this at all but you know
that's their sentiment it's like oh
you're an open micro when i first saw
you you're probably never going to
progress past that yeah i mean i get to
la i'm eight years in and people like oh
damn this is a polished
thing you can cut the line and get into
these real shows
um and so
there's different ways to do it though
there's i mean because i know a bunch of
people that start in la and new york and
they're fine yeah but i'm also i'm from
la so i think for me that's an advantage
because i when you know grew up here
also went to college here so i have a
bunch of people that you know you do
these like smaller shows or whatever
where it's like they expect you to bring
people and you'll get booked on again if
you bring people i can always get people
to show up where
maybe you just like move to resent those
shows yeah but not even that it's like i
have a quota where i have to bring these
people but it's like you're doing a show
at this place
and they're like all right well this guy
brought you know 10 people we didn't
like give him a quota but he brought
people like let's bring him back again
no that's definitely you do that in
every city too yeah and then you'll
realize three years in that none of your
friends takes you back anymore
and then you'll be alone
and you'll be really funny no yeah
i have some friends
and you'll have crippling i'll like
invite some friends who are like oh like
i want to see you do stuff
offer you that shelter
midday
no
no but i always say everyone wants to
see you do stand up until there's like a
date and time because and then you're
like oh i have a show and they're like
sorry man but then when you see them in
person when you see them like oh i want
to see you do stand up and then you give
them like a time and place and they're
like oh sorry you can't make it oh yeah
shout out cortland leoy
you know people also picture going to
see you as like this packed room and you
just barely got them a seat in this
place to watch not like
they're sitting next to other comment
comics like you can see them looking in
there
they're like yeah it can be
very sad
what we do
but that's the grind it's that was
trying to like i was talking about this
recently like explaining to other people
what we do
you're an insane person it's like well
yeah i'm actually but i'm gonna go out
tonight i'm not even booked on the show
but if i show up they might throw me up
there's probably gonna be eight people
there um it's in a sparse room
none of these people are really gonna
wanna be there we're gonna force this
comedy on them right after monday night
football
and uh they're gonna probably hate all
of us but yeah that's what i'm going to
do tonight sweetheart
i can't go to dinner
tell your parents maybe to travel on a
better night
do you
find that you don't think anybody else
is funny when you're there most like
there's
up with a lot of bad people no not to be
not to judge other people's stuff but
that's
i mean when that's why i was like why am
i here because i'm just like every
person who went up they were just like
and i wasn't good i'm not saying i was
funny but i'm like oh you're all bad
yeah
i literally quit my job not to do
stand-up comedy but work in the industry
i guess
uh i did like 40 open mics funny or die
and you died uh that was in the middle
that was that was when i was like okay
i'll get a nine to five
[Applause]
no i find people
yeah i find people very unfunny but uh
i'm also at a point where i'm around
people that i'm like oh
i'm my my friends are some of the
funniest people in the industry now it's
cool like i mean obviously we referenced
him earlier but like my best friend is
chappelle lacy he's killing it uh i
would never sit through a thing and be
like this guy [ __ ] sucks i mean
you know he's making up a story about
having multiple fathers and [ __ ] like
come on
raised by a white family i know that's a
lie you know like
no i get to see that like i get to like
be around my peers are now people that
we've grinded with together and then
we're all super funny and then i do have
to go sit in rooms you know that
you'll have to sit in and get up on mics
and a lot of people suck yeah and it's
hard to
and then you have to surround yourself
with these people that are trying to
tell you how to improve but you're like
i just saw you
you suck
um and you should probably quit
uh you know i have a sentiment about
that i think more people should quit for
sure um but
it is something that if you you got to
be delusional about it at the beginning
you're you're two years in you're
probably not great you're probably not
bad either though if you're still doing
it and [ __ ] like that you've got enough
reactions hopefully where you're self
aware that these are going okay yeah
yeah uh but you'll be three four years
in after this you'll be like at a five
year point and you'll look at the jokes
you're telling right now and you're like
what the [ __ ] was i doing and that's not
saying anything about your jokes right
now it's just a thing the way you have
it yeah no i remember like when i
started out in new york i thought it was
so good like i did a bringer show at
broadway comedy club like i got this
tape it's so good or whatever
and now like
you probably can't even watch yeah it's
like i'm just like jeez i'm like people
were telling me like oh you're so good
it's just like but i guess now since i'm
like i've gotten better
um just like weird to look back and some
of the jokes are like the same but it's
just like they've expanded on them and
made them so much better you'll go
revisit all jokes and you have a
different voice because you understand
how to maintain yourself on stage it's a
crazy thing we do but it's one of the
best it's the most rewarding thing in
the world if you can get good at it you
can figure out more about yourself and
you can never do anything else you're
alone on that stage nobody's there if
you're failing you're failing by
yourself yeah and it's a beautiful thing
when that doesn't happen yeah um but
yeah it's it's good good luck but also
quit
when you guys go on stage or and you you
have that say the
i guess open micros go on before you and
they suck yeah do you guys are you like
oh [ __ ] i don't feel that as good
anymore or do you feel like oh [ __ ] i'm
gonna kill it now
yeah cause the guys sucked before you
guys and girls i mean i sometimes say
[ __ ] up [ __ ] about them if they're bad
but i mean you feel more confident
i'll be like oh he wrote down a joke
about raping his cousin and
it's crazy that he wrote that down and
then said it out loud
strangers
and thought that would go well but um
no i
yeah i mean i'm never worried
i get i'm at a point where right now so
i guess this is yeah yeah yeah
um does it bum you on you you don't feel
as good or do you actually feel like oh
[ __ ] i'm better i'm gonna kill you no i
definitely feels good when you can
clearly tell that you're better than
some of the other people going up but
also i still get like
i'm confident in my material but
sometimes i get if like i have new
friends or whatever coming in i'm like
[ __ ] if this is the first time they see
me do stand up and you know what if it's
a show that you know doesn't go well and
then you're just like that's the
impression they have like you go around
telling people your comic then they go
see you and it sucks
that's always kind of i'm afraid of but
i am like confident in my material i'm
just i'm i don't think it's going to
happen but i'm like oh what if what if
it does when i did it i never would have
told anybody i know to go see me that's
what i was gonna say too it's i mean
uh yeah i had an awareness early on i
was like i'm not gonna tell anybody i'm
doing this for like a year
yeah and that's how i was for a long
time but now i'm like okay i am
confident getting confident in this
material where it's like
i want to like you know make it another
step where it's like okay yeah and it's
a completely different thing now too the
funny thing is i'm 10 years in as of
april and if i could tell you advice on
what to do
it actually doesn't even apply you
shouldn't even listen to me because you
should probably just be making clips and
putting them on tick tock and like yeah
putting them on instagram reels and [ __ ]
like that like
my advice would be get the material
right work your [ __ ] ass off
sacrifice don't party on the weekends go
to the clubs network do all that [ __ ]
write create but now it's like i don't
know [ __ ] tell a weird joke at an
open mic film it and edit it the right
way you could change your life
uh
i think that's also creation mike uh
you said because you were like the the
old it was kind of a joke because like i
i look at the same way you do it's like
a different
and i'm just a fan of it but like i've
i've listened to a lot of marc maron
earl in the early days talk to comics
and jerk them off uh you were like they
have to create and like let the work
speak for itself yeah but these people
who are popping off on tick tock and
[ __ ]
it is but it is its own creation they're
creating in a completely i think wrong
way because you're telling me a
half-assed joke that in six months would
be way better if you just worked on it
but you're gonna put it up because it's
so fleeting
uh kind of half-assed and you're not
you're gonna edit out the audience noise
because nobody did laugh but you edit it
in a way where it's just like oh that's
the joke
um so it's kind of weird i've seen a lot
less
sounds like open mic tick-tock than you
like
like i'm not even onto my [ __ ] thing
my algorithm's all [ __ ] up but like a
chappelle lacy clip he usually puts up
something that he cut
from
he's on some half hour that got put out
and it's polished and it's well produced
so that's what i'm thinking
that's like what's he's getting two
million views on [ __ ] dude i know people
that are [ __ ] killing it
and i don't even want to name names
because i don't know you know they're
probably bigger than me they'll be a
[ __ ] be working for them in five
years right but it is just not funny
uh but they might be you know not to
generalize but sometimes it's an
attractive girl
that is saying something that is not a
joke
that's my biggest thing is i love call
me crazy i'm a sucker for punchlines
um and sometimes they won't even [ __ ]
say a punchline and it just pops because
they say something that's triggering to
a community uh or like not even
triggering i shouldn't say but like i
know what you mean yeah yeah like
they're saying like the these the most
woke thing they can say and it's like
all right well what if you just put a
joke in there with a premise and a twist
we got mike fired up yeah i [ __ ] hate
it
i even
saw it in your eyes but it sounded like
i was defending the dick
you were like oh no i'm ready to talk
some of them oh yeah i don't know
adobe pro tools and all that [ __ ] that's
who i believe that being said you got
some [ __ ] good ass content on your
social medias uh but like you're saying
that they're half-assing and throwing up
an open mic
the street [ __ ] is fired the the man on
this is so good i appreciate that yeah
that that stuff's been very fun to do
for me i'm gonna keep doing it i got a
company that i'm gonna partner with in
la here oh yeah dude do some more [ __ ]
on melrose [ __ ] people on melrose
and then um
what can be your bing bong
yeah well how do i give you a big bomb i
think i'm just gonna hate on 20 year
olds really is all i'm gonna do because
i just i'm like what the [ __ ] um
so i appreciate that and then yeah like
when i had a clip
i do don't tell comedy in uh la and
we're national if you're anywhere go
look up don't tell comedy we're doing
great shows there and we're filming a
lot of young comics putting them on the
map having them pop off and i had a clip
from there go like 7 million
which is cool damn so that helps
[ __ ] like that but that was a
structured joke
that i wrote curated
was honest and truthful
like hemingway up there
yeah don't tell comedy and then look up
our youtube is going crazy right now
um
so we're at like 300 000
[Music]
something on youtube i know chappelle's
got a set up there that's
reached like yeah i watched hey okay
yeah yeah i remember they're going crazy
right now oh he just subscribed look at
you
so yeah what are the subscriber numbers
at 349k so if you want to like if you're
out there and you enjoy stand-up comedy
like these are the names that
you should know uh that you don't know
that they might not be on netflix yet
these are the names i want to get in
here if they're willing to come out to
calabasas because it is easy these are
great people these are some of the
funniest yeah chappelle's is like number
two right now which is crazy because
we've released so many
uh
420 i mean
look at that
look at that 16 million bro
some of the biggest visibility that
we've had on the entire uh
numbies um zombies yeah
yeah big big numbers 1.3 million likes
damn all the comments and [ __ ] eight
point four okay
so he's killing it on there um he
crushes people on that clip with facial
expressions like only he he he
me and him always talk about we love
bernie mac
we were talking about earlier and bernie
we watched king's comedy a couple times
right during the pandemic
he could tell
a joke with his eyes
and he's he's actively been working on
that the past
few years and it's very cool to see it
because i know that
it's cool knowing a guy that intimately
and then seeing it go out on stage
because me and him talk about this [ __ ]
and it's like oh he works at it and it
and it hits
because yeah i mean half of his [ __ ]
he'll go up on stage sometimes and for
two minutes not tell a joke
and it's just looking at the audience
and you're laughing
that's hard [ __ ]
so you know take notes bro
no i'm kidding don't tell me
[Applause]
i have
thought of and forgotten so many things
i wanted to talk about during this
conversation which i said last week was
good pod because you go so many
directions yeah yeah
i thought of one we were talking about
roasting like the previous oprah
microsoft is not good because that's
that's easy
one time
i went with
a friend of a friend i wanted to
delineate myself from him but we went to
an open mic in minneapolis minnesota
acme comedy club sure and good club huh
uh good club uh uh i worked the door
there for a year loved that club just it
was it was great
especially it's so much different in
here because the comment comes in for a
week and you see him five nights for an
hour at a time i love seeing people
multiple times but uh
so we go with this guy and he goes up
there and
i'm told he's been doing
i don't know this is like mankato
minnesota he's doing time
and but i've heard he's he's been up a
lot and he's pretty comfortable he's
pretty funny actually yeah that's the
word you hear when someone brings you to
their friend he's pretty funny actually
well if they say they're funny that's
good if they say they're nice that's not
good yeah yeah yeah
how's he nice guy uh
and it wasn't the actual person who
brought me that said he was funny but
someone told me he was pretty funny and
he just starts telling like
old like
school yard racist jokes oh yeah like
i can't think of punch lines but this is
like one how many how many mexicans are
running down the hill how many and
there's like a punch line to all of it
yes some racist stereotype or something
or like the boondock saints oliver coke
uh if anybody remembers the reference
hilarious jokes that i won't retell but
incredible racist joke but
oh my god i was thinking of the show
boondocks i was like yeah me too yeah
it's a good movie great movie
yeah that they i
but but yeah so he
he goes up there and he does five
minutes of this to
stun silence
and
the next comic
comes up oh and this was look this is a
contest this is the funniest person in
many ways
the next guy comes up and it might be
the hardest i've ever laughed at comedy
club he's like oh man i was gonna do my
tight five on a-wraps but
that's just it i mean but that was the
guy i was with yeah we were like we have
to escape we call that a heisman friend
you gotta keep him right here
um
the
yeah i mean i love so i do a show that's
called this week's sucks tonight that's
a very funny show we do it at the
hollywood improv and then we do it in
san diego in phoenix me and my buddy
anwar newton started it five years ago
we do a lot of the news that's going on
in the news cycle and then we bring
comics up and comics we put anybody up
uh we don't really care if you're great
or you're not great or whatever
uh but when they're not great we are
literally both on stage with them
just talking [ __ ] uh when it doesn't go
well or like i might say something about
what they wore or whatever like that but
that's why we we love the show because i
i have a pretty unique skill set of
[ __ ]
cutting into [ __ ] um like hit that one
hit the clip uh
with
in the middle on the bottom right there
and hit the audio on that so this is
kind of the show but we say [ __ ] up
[ __ ] sometimes but this isn't even
anything mean about her said it's just i
can't understand why black people always
kill each other
[Music]
and i was like i don't understand why
white people kill everybody
fire
we don't see color when we get a gun
and we just get to say one [ __ ] like
that
so we're both on stage saying [ __ ]
we don't see color when we got a gun in
our hand and uh that's just fun
uh but like we're able to clap back if
they go to the maybe the next one i
think is lower peak or uh yeah we make
fun of how i look like kyle rittenhouse
thursday thursday at 8 pm phoenix hit
that one in the middle yeah
this is a fun one i think laura peak
who's one of my favorite
michael
you look like a 40 year old intern at
the republican national convention
you look like you masturbate to the
twilight series
so it's a very fun show but to your
point with like people going up and
being bad the best thing about that show
is we can call it out right in the
moment now those are good comics but
we'll get like oh
yeah we'll get some bad people somebody
was just doing jokes last week about
how
these restaurants are actually just
disguised as
uh like this greek restaurant is
actually just an italian mob restaurant
and stuff like that he generalized that
and then i just started going off it's
like and the wing place is just a black
restaurant and then it's like replaced
be a greek mob restaurant that's what i
was saying yeah it didn't make sense
um but we just hate on people a lot
the great johnny moss he's he's on his
he's one of our favorite magic
what the [ __ ] is your glasses he's got a
look it cuts off seven years
you look 82. you look like you look like
weezer but in a different way oh that's
a comic named johnny moss
the blue album because you can't breathe
[ __ ]
it was also part of the beakerton so it
walks out
it's really [ __ ] up
guess he's got a [ __ ] quarterback
wristband
this is just a fun ass show
america should know more about it and
johnny moss is one of our best people
he's actually unfortunately
cancer hospice right now oh no not doing
great and so we've been putting them up
on a couple shows through zoom just to
give him the love but uh good dude in
phoenix and always one of our best
guests because we just [ __ ] make fun
of old white men
and he is not the 1960s uh boston
play-by-play announcement no no no he's
just an old guy that got beat up by
puerto ricans in the 70s and always had
a disdain for them ever since is johnny
moss thank you christian it instincts
fact check me
was he
what
he's a british social services director
johnny moss celtics
leading the witness
this is great
and then also i want to watch that uh
firecracker thing johnny most after oh
the how was it most is it most probably
pretty it could be pronounced one letter
off i would like to say
it is
fact check that
but that that show is also meant to make
comics quick comedy
you have i like the man who sticks to
the plan it's all it's all on the
company that's really hard
idea you got any news george
yeah i got some news [ __ ]
let's see oh my god what was the news do
you watch joe dirt 2 this weekend
actually look at the lord you guys want
to play a little game
so last time i saw nick he was a little
bit intoxicated we watched this show
called below deck
oh yeah
that's chinchill yeah well we watch it
together
yeah we all watch why is it chin's show
just did not get pissed off in just a
bit i'm not pissed isn't it about asians
uh coming over oh no that's like
oh i know
you're talking about what is that called
you know what about i like the titanic
not like that but uh what is that no i
know i know exactly
why no it's not like it was like an
empire no it's a sitcom on like nbc's
yeah yeah it's very popular because i
always saw the commercials for it you're
kidding right now well yeah no no no
everyone go check out another below deck
podcast and learn more about this
awesome show yeah
i had about six claws as we recorded
this last weekend and then after we were
done i made everybody watch below deck
mediterranean oh nice i got i got the
pilot a week early from bravo pr sure
because those funnier diet connections
you sensed it i got a little heated
because you're like yeah that's your
show no that's my
show
the number one podcast
number one podcast to this tv show fresh
off the boat that's what it's like
[ __ ]
that's what you're talking about you
know what i'm like well no no kind of
fresh off the boat yeah that's a good
joke asians underneath
you jerks
fresh under the boat at least
below the deck i said bling empire at
least they're billionaires
fresh off the boat they're just yeah
i mean hopefully she's getting the
actors are doing very well yeah this guy
is in everything he plays i feel like
everybody randall kim i met him too he
was such a cool dude is he i met him
before he's good really famous yeah he's
well i remember when he was jim in the
office that was a very funny he did make
the office after a long time before
oh really yeah he's doing really well i
met him at a bar
at a grand star cafe in los angeles
chinatown he was by himself just
chilling really having a drink and i'm
like dude i've seen you and stuff man
i appreciate everything you do he's like
oh thank you and then he just started
blowing up
yeah he's he's done really well for
himself
yeah him ronnie chang ronnie chang's
killer too and then whoever who is the
main dude in uh chiang chi
shang chi he's see me lou he's doing
i mean he's doing fine just because of
that i don't
didn't you got a spreadsheet
i know three asians
yeah
what about what do you got more news
busters yeah i got so we last time i saw
nick he was talking about this uh
this ai
generating thing
called dolly is that what it's called
salvador yeah that's uh it's a
portmanteau of wally and salvador dali
it's an image generator important
to create image
and they will
destroy photographers so i want you guys
to try to guess
what sentence i typed in to get these
sets of images
i love the game great radio game this is
the kind of initiative we're looking for
dana white red sauce
dana white red sauce
it's dana white eating pizza yeah ding
ding ding i'll just say dana white
[ __ ] friday that's why i [ __ ]
around with dolly the image generator so
i know so this is actually just dolly
mini they have a dolly too to give
context can you go to uh instagram.com
with an e your ex-girlfriend named karen
you memorized instagram usernames uh she
was on a podcast that i produced so i
had to like put it in text uh go to the
one
the
second
uh second row to the left
her face yeah yeah that one
magazine
cosmo but that would be different than
every other cover before it because this
one would be their first magazine cover
generated by artificial intelligence
what would it look like i started off by
getting on a call with the cosmo team to
discuss the creative direction of the
cover we wanted to represent a pilot if
it's just dana white
[Laughter]
but none of them felt quite right this
one for example was too boxy can't
really tell she's a woman
okay that's better but let's get her
walking tour looks like a woman to me
okay better but i don't love her can we
get everything more confident
each time i adjusted my prompt over and
over again refining it to try to get the
right image and after many many hours of
trying hundreds of props
i finally figured out the right one it
was
a wide-angle shot from below of a female
astronaut with an athletic feminine body
walking with swagger towards camera on
mars in an infinite universe comma
synthwave digital art and drumroll
here's how it turned out
[Music]
damn cool she made that with the
freaking internet that's pretty crazy
so all she had to do was type that in
and that came out yeah but that's not
available to the public that's dolly too
i'm on the wait list i don't think i'll
get it you need like a following
she's like a huge creator
uh
and that's what she does is like weird
internet videos like that i don't know
um but so that's that's the context of
the game we're playing yeah the the very
my new one that's available to the
public so i think so people can't like
fake crimes uh i don't think
we can have this
chin stealing the thing i stole
yesterday oh i said
minority report
wait what is this called dolly
the one
i got two more but i took away a couple
of the photos to try to make it a little
harder i like it okay so
uh let's go to the set of three the
production let's see david
eating kentucky fried chicken yeah ooh
that is very close
there's a theme
with
just big
it's his desires and his fears all right
it's dave batista at a kfc
oh well yeah i was right yeah you were
very right and let's
so i'm hopping into our ad meeting guys
all right peace out george good luck i
feel like that really gives a really
good feel behind the scenes that he has
to leave and go do business that's the
kind of i like that
that's the kind of bar stool feel i'm
looking for one so you're telling me you
had
uh dave bautista was dining in on that
one that was weird yeah and now can you
guys guess what this one is
what i know i just no i just looked at
mike and look at the lights
kind of bright
it's a new light i don't even know what
that is
i mean it's a ufc fighter yeah so i
don't know who that is it's a white bald
ufc fighter which is
almost everyone on the roster it's a
rare ufc fighter that you know
oh that's chuckled
yeah oh oh
where is he
he's at the carnival circus circus yeah
he's at the circus eating what though
he's nice why are the images so
weird yeah that's how the ai generates
oh it's like a dream sequence i was
gonna say it looks like someone who's
just trapped in the basement's trying to
like draw for help you guys wanna black
ass beta [ __ ] available to the public so
like that frame well the other one was
you guys
type one in on the on the fly and see
see where it comes so dolly mini
yeah
if you want it's d-a-l-e
d-o-l-e
as we're bringing it up we gotta think
of one put it in because it takes like
two minutes sometimes
yeah so what do you what do you guys
want to type in
uh i'll just write something no the rock
giving the rock bottom to stone cold
steve austin in wrestlemania 23.
that's that could quite possibly just be
a picture i know
yeah yeah yeah
no i think they were both retired by 23.
that might have been stone cold with the
knee bridge you have to probably repeat
that because he's not going to be yeah
yeah
the rock
giving the rock bottom
do i spell that right now
they just both have iphones
hey buddy to stone cold steve austin
it's the picture you're thinking of but
they're holding iphones
uh at wrestlemania
just put wrestlemania
that's fun
george where where can they find you
they can find me
at uh george harris48 on instagram or on
youtube at
youtube.com forward slash go george go
that is my little vlogs please subscribe
[ __ ] yeah i'm excited how are your
youtube numbers hidden uh they're
actually pretty decent for i started my
channel when i first came out here at
the beginning of may i have like
i got a total of of seven dislikes on my
whole youtube so i feel like my numbers
that's huge positive and low i mean
you're not crossed
out yeah people yeah if you dislike
i actively dislike it in real life and
and listen i
i know all those dislikes coming are all
levels you got some good views for yeah
you just started this [ __ ] heck yeah
thank you for the cats after dark
numbies boost that's better you guys
i just did the last time i was on here i
probably had like 98 subscribers i now
have five point
six k or something hey i don't know what
happened you had more before that so how
dare you
you did not have how much i only had
three four months ago i had 98. you're
kidding yeah
so i started doing the shorts you're a
little more
but uh
oh look at that
but he's not giving him the rock bottom
yeah right there is that it i mean it's
like maybe right after it it sounds like
easy to do
it's [ __ ] giving them the people's
elbow yeah i guess i'm looking for a
video more than an image we need it we
need it what is the google search of
that exact sentence just google search
that and i just oh the rock giving stone
gold the rock bottom go to images
yeah he probably is he's definitely
giving him the rock bottom oh there it
is there we go
yeah
at wrestlemania
they yeah they had to fight at
wrestlemania of course
17 i was actually thinking 17. that's a
good wrestlemania
um oh triple that was a triple threat
match between him and triple h and the
rock
that's amazing that's a
now i want to go watch that
sometimes shut up triple h triple h is
the greatest heal of all time he just
refused wwe matches and i'm not i don't
really i don't watch wrestling currently
but like that's my era i mean like
attitude era yeah
yeah i was raised by john luke picard
and vince mcmahon oh yeah wwe i was a
jericho guy i wore out my [ __ ] king
of the ring 98 [ __ ] vhs watching the
hell in the cell undertaker and mankind
oh sure over and over i do a joke about
that hell yeah but george watching that
yeah no well anybody watching it i
usually i look at a guy on the crowd and
i'm like you look like you know where
you were when undertaker threw mankind
through that cage
and it's a very specific looking guy
and it blows the place up so if it's the
right crowd they're like yeah i was
someplace on monday morning because we
didn't get the pay-per-views
yeah honestly dude shout out to mimi
turner she uh
she knew that we would stay home on a
sunday if she bought them all and we
weren't like flush with cash we weren't
like
too well off but it was 30 bucks that
she put aside every month and we watched
all this uh pay-per-views
and she got into it because then and
then you realize then your mom's into it
and you realize that it's just a
male 1 soap opera yeah oh yeah that's
what was my biggest realization i was
like why are you so into this
it's like oh i watched drama i watched a
lot of y and r with my grandma so i
always knew that [ __ ] goes hard oh yeah
dude
what's weiner young and the wrists oh
gnl dude
i forget which one i used to watch it
you're kind of separated if you're if
you're uh
i don't know whatever general hospital
was on i was a cbs guy guiding light
bold and beautiful
yeah i would think i was cbs uh
as the world turns and guiding light
that was the foursome and then they
started just dropping off bold and
beautiful ynr still going strong nick
newman victor newman they're still going
oh yeah i remember there was a dude that
was definitely dead for like 17 episodes
and then like one day he just came out
of the coma
all the story arcs and those were the
best that's everything yeah yeah i love
those though it's so ridiculous so you
know tech talk let's do a little tech
talk here with uh not tick tock but tech
talk tech yeah first camera frame rate
skin's got a segment no camera frame
rates remember soap operas it felt so
real like it wasn't like it was like a
video camera when you watched him right
it's not like a movie movies are filmed
like in 24 frames
but those soap operas are for what
60 frames or something like that right i
think back in the day they were 30 when
[ __ ] was [ __ ] was 24 but now they're
probably 60. or it just seems like
they're really there and it didn't feel
like you're out you're watching a tv
show or a movie it felt like a little
like yeah weird you you're never no i
guess i don't know enough about frame
rates but that does make sense but
you're like different yeah you're like
you're in the room with yeah it's like
there's i didn't like it there's also
some weird meme about
i never really noticed it but like on
new tvs there's like cinema motion
blurring that then made it like give
that soap opera smoothing or something
like that
yeah and people hated that look i hate
these they thought it made it look weird
and stuff but it came became the default
setting on people's plans plasma and
tech doc thus far has been fascinating
what a segment
and that is
so they made the movies into soap operas
after that point because though after
the motion smoothing it because it
looked too real everything was too real
i want to i want to feel like i'm
distant from what's going on on the
screen interesting unless you want to be
a part of the the stuff and then yeah
that's cool you want to go really inside
baseball any podcast you watch with me
on it or that i have edited is 24 frames
because it's lower file size and there's
we're not [ __ ] flying around i love
that for you yeah
that's big that's it that's a note for
all you guys out there uh we'll keep
plugging stuff since we're talking about
wrestling this is a great time to plug
another podcast show i'm gonna do a deep
dive on jimmy snuka killing his wife
yeah on on the show you gonna get to
chris benoit with the old murder sui i
have i have a chris benoit action figure
at my work desk and that's scary man
r.i.p to him and his fam yeah one some
of them yeah see i wasn't alive during
the jimmy snooker stuff so i can still
make it yeah funny the chris benoit
stuff
the stuff i know vince mcmahon covered
up a lot of stuff they say that's what
we might i had heard it back in the day
uh that he had killed his wife and they
just never talked about it they just
like
acted like uh it didn't happen i've
always suggested that's where people
should kill people uh boats yeah in the
ocean yeah that's where george hamilton
killed that woman and uh
but he got away with it
i don't know where i heard it one time
but someone did a thesis on like their
or their final thing in forensics was
how would you kill a body and if you had
like a good way that so professor's
obviously killing people and he's
getting serious but uh someone who got
an a was take him out in the ocean
dump them yeah ocean's big
since when they dumped uh bin laden
you know did they though just kidding i
met rob o'neill i think they did yeah i
think they did do that i don't know
anything about him but i did shake his
hand but they might not have yeah i
don't know they lied to us the
government's never lied to us about
stuff like that though
no i don't know anymore
i used to get upset when people said 9
11 was an inside job it's time to get
plugs in
i guess you want to talk about youtube
links i've got some youtube links in my
like six hours
that is true yeah yeah follow your boy
dude my turn or white mike i i will say
turner comedy subscribe if you go
michael turner mike turner on instagram
you don't come up i don't know i it
might be a bad seo for you bro michael
turner yeah i don't know maybe why i got
to fix that huh mike turner comedy mike
yeah
so i talked to the guy that is michael
turner he's got 600 followers and he
makes pizza the running back for the no
he's not he doesn't have anything
no this dude that's in baltimore that
makes pizzas
but uh i think michael turner played in
baltimore didn't he no he was a charger
in a
falcon and he won a fantasy football
league for me for a lot of people yeah
he was good that in like
2008 he had a really great year so don't
search his name white mike mike mike
turner yeah look at michael turner
comedy at turner turner comedy yeah
on everything
tian
um shoot i
thought i had stuff in my head i know
this for a fact though so i just got
another tattoo which no one noticed
some of y'all did something check out my
new ink
wait the whole sleeve because we saw the
sleeve
so i want to just give a shout out to my
guy oh [ __ ]
johnny from
mojave creative at in santa monica he's
a amazing tattoo artist he did this one
as well my
my first ever really big long sleeve
thing so shout out to him and just my
youtube channel and my yeah instagram
chinsuyi
tizzle
christian
just uh my instagram see palo 6 and
that's about it
and keenan thompson's podcasters yeah
dude oh yeah i'm doing this all on his
network i just realized too so you can
subscribe to keane
thompson's podcast it's called you
already know with keenan thompson and
tani monroe
so hell yeah dude shout out to king and
kale i actually i was romantic
july 13th
live podcast another podcast show with
kate casey from reality life with kkk
there you go irvine improv 200 tickets
sold so far nice that's good that's a
big venue we're not we're not it's she's
the marquee or whatever but we've pushed
hard and we have a devoted dude that's
nice that's great yeah yeah i think they
have to oh because it's like they were
going to do the front i think they have
to like now open up the back
yeah
getting into the back for sure
that's a big old venue right there july
13th so
uh
i don't know how long we're even gonna
be on stage but i'll drink with you
after the show i promise you that's big
july 13th
who could forget it uh
any live shows coming up can we see i
have july 13th i'll be in phoenix
arizona doing this week's sex tonight oh
that sucks and then i'll be
right back
and then uh
but then i'll be back in at the
hollywood improv it'll be august though
august 26th we'll be back uh doing this
week's extra night in hollywood again so
that'll be fun and then yeah don't tell
comedy we do every weekend i'm somewhere
around here so hit me on instagram if
you want to come see a show dm me and
i'll tell you where to go
and there's george's instagram george
yeah jordan
oh yeah good call
oh yeah nice boy yeah nice boy let's get
him on hey hopefully he doesn't quit
he's croatian yeah right let's get him
on your side
i'll put him on this week sucks tonight
yeah let's do it it could go bad for him
it'll be a segment nice boy it'll be
content that would actually be good yeah
i'll get him on yeah that'd be dope
we'll do that put him through the ringer
yeah yeah it's a fun shot it's a
dollywood improv too
it's a big time
sweet
what did you plug your
[ __ ] nick i did watch the podcast show
and the yeah the live show
davis did
real nick davis no that's
oh i'm also gonna shout out maybe we'll
do this as a segment i'm in a uh
instagram group chat with all nick
davises
uh there's about 25 of us
and actually we're some pretty
accomplished fellas uh i'm actually i'm
i'm embarrassed to be in there i mean
one of these guys [ __ ] abs for days
that's that's basically he posts a lot
of stuff he's jacked and [ __ ] but we do
all sorts of things so maybe we'll talk
to another nick davis oh my god
yeah michael turner's like a very common
name so there's a bunch of us cats after
dark
i remember google uh tried a social
media thing what was that called google
circle or something
it was bad but the only thing that ever
happened with my google social media was
a michael turner
a bunch of michael turner's all followed
each other
google plus
and then it was called
yeah that this is google circles yeah
that failed so hard
if there's a chin ce meetup group let's
do it
is that the world name what's up is that
a common name i don't i doubt it i doubt
all right we have to go all right let's
call him this show ciao
meetup group
[Music]
so
you